okay
hello folks welcome to rational science
you only said on the internet that does
physics rationally
we have a great day today I'm gonna
have some of the questions answered up
front because
um some people asked uh types of
questions or made comments regarding uh
some of the topics of Extinction and
also of Dimensions which is what we've
been doing lately and so I'm just gonna
be
you know having a lecture together with
answering the question
so we're going to begin with topics
related to Extinction that I've raised
lately and some people had questions or
made comments about them here's a
synthesis of what I'm going to cover
okay uh disease conspiracy
homosexuality has been around since the
beginning of time
is caused by old age uh pregnancies
women get pregnant at the wrong time
atheism is not a religion uh-huh
and God is got an object or a concept
uh kind of interesting or important to
answer that question If You're Gonna
try to find out whether God exists or
not right uh because before you can talk
about existence I think you first have
to determine whether God is an object or
a concept you know does the table exist
well uh is the table an object or is it
a concept does it matter does love exist
you know these are the questions we're
referring to anyways let's go with the
first one here we have one gentleman and
he makes a comment okay that we've been
dealing with uh more or less lately okay
so I'm gonna try to answer him and he
says the following he says what have we
learned from Bill Gates about uh patents
he's referring to my uh federal case I
had a federal case okay we have learned
that companies never patent uh their
sequential work processes for example a
microchip
in other words he's referring to the
specifications right and I'm sure that
Pfizer you know a company this is a
company that does health things uh drugs
right never patented their modifications
either okay why should the competitors
make big money why should Pfizer
voluntarily give the blueprints into the
hands of its competitors but if they did
patent it the patent itself could have
been a trojan horse so you can blame the
enemy okay okay
so uh I know a little bit about this
subject because I researched it for my
federal case and I can tell you one
thing is that you cannot patent a
process you cannot copyright a process
okay Camp patent or copyrighted why and
there are several reasons I'm just going
to give you one that I'm sure you're
going to be able to uh
you know absorb very quickly and that is
that a process like you know
specifications to build a chip could be
the specifications to build a drug uh
say an antibiotic or whatever out there
um those change constantly
you know we used to change the specs
almost every day and uh and for example
in my case I would uh change the specs
maybe on the average anywhere between
one and two weeks and we had our
engineering manager his name was uh
Preston snugs he became vice president
of AMD later on of devices and Preston
you know he would receive uh specs from
different Engineers so he probably was
signing specs every day you know maybe I
modified them once a week but for sure
he he had lots on his desk and uh so we
modified the uh the process
on a periodical basis you know you
receive new machines or you find a
better way of doing a process or
whatever you have to change the spec
and so you cannot patent every time you
change the spec
okay you can see that that's a problem
so process cannot be patented and
process cannot be uh uh copyrighted so
they invented you know the secret uh
copyright the secret patent so to speak
you know patents are things you uh put
in uh public uh domain so that the
government knows what it's protecting
here they invented the invisible patent
you know you can patent without
registering it you have protection
without protect without registering so
that's more or less what happened but
yeah you cannot patent or copyright a
process okay so just keep that in mind
okay uh one argument against that
there's more than that but I'll just
give you that for now so you have
something to think about
another fellow brings up another issue
says you can uh analyze homosexuality
but it has been around as long as humans
has it
homosexuals are born that way they do
not have a choice yeah we see eye to eye
on that issue I think that's that's the
case
um hermaphrodites have both male and
female genitalia Etc Val Lucifer has
both XX and XY
chromosomes are both are are both male
and female genitalia and is a
hermaphrodite uh-huh
not sure what you're saying there okay
if the Ancients thought this then uh
that too has been around for his back
for uh as far back as before BC okay the
first thing we need to address is Battle
Bell uh was modified over the centuries
okay bow is not always a bad guy okay in
fact uh in uh even today bow just means
uh the head of the god something like
Zeus okay over time you know some people
uh converted bowel into a bad word and
he became like the devil and then they
put different Sexes to him so we don't
know when all that happened that's the
first thing we would have to research
okay but I can only give you my uh five
cents worth and I've been investigating
homosexuality since
1985. I know that for a fact that's what
uh 38 years ago for 38 years on and off
it's not like I investigated every day
but I think I know a little bit about
homeless sexuality not because I'm
homosexual
no but there's other reasons too lengthy
to cover today uh things that happen uh
in my life with other people and so I
had to start investigating them and
um one of the things I can share with
you today is what I found out over the
centuries okay since then and here's the
first one okay this is for you to take
into consideration a lot of people think
that
homosexuals
become according to what they eat or how
they were raised by their mothers or
pressure from society or who knows what
you know and I agree with this other
fellow I have the same uh Foundation
homosexuals are born that way okay they
can't do anything about it just like
you're born maybe looking at the right
sex the women you know or women looking
at men you know that's the same standard
right and these people are born with
their brains in such a way that they're
looking at the wrong sex okay at the
same sex and that is the wrong sex and
you know I'll tell you why it's a wrong
sex because uh sex was invented probably
by plants that's my guess uh plants had
sex before I think animals and maybe
simultaneously but I would lean towards
plants and we're talking about here the
cambian you know way way back when
but the issue is uh sex was made for
reproduction and same-sex is not
reproduction no matter how you twist and
turn it and so uh there's something that
is changing and I think it's lately okay
this has not been there forever so uh
here's the first bit of evidence that
I'll put forward okay and here we have
the code of unamu and uh here you see
other codes uh all the way to
Hammurabi's Code and you see the dates
more or less they're about two thousand
years before Christ anywhere between
1700 to 2000 years before Christ none of
them dealt with the issue of
homosexuality which is quite a
coincidence I mean these uh are cities
from different places they're nearby
they're in the Middle East but there are
different places and none of them
mention homosexuality or anything in the
code punishes homosexuality or favors it
for that matter right okay so you won't
see it there which is kind of quite
interesting at least for you to take
into consideration doesn't mean you have
to believe it or reject it or whatever
just keep it in mind okay some people
get all excited okay uh here's another
bit of evidence this is the Book of the
Dead of the Egyptians about 1500 years
before Christ and this was uh something
that a person who was about to die had
to confess because otherwise they would
not go to heaven and there's only a
piece there that I show of the entire
um Papyrus you can look it up you'll
find that it's a very long Papyrus and
essentially the the person who was dying
had to confess uh many things and among
them this was one of them that he had
not had sexual relations with another
person of the same sex now that same
passage has been translated differently
by different people some of those
especially the last two are homosexuals
and so they uh some of them try to cover
it up some don't but the point is that
you know this is a passage that is in
the Book of the Dead and you might want
to consider it also when you think about
whether you know homosexuality was here
forever you know since the beginning of
man
but uh here's the first instance where
homosexuality appears in the books okay
and it was in the code of Asura okay uh
this is the evidence that we do have
maybe maybe it happened before this but
we don't have any evidence of it okay so
this is a fact that you can look up
was from the days of uh the Assyrian
Empire that's why it's called Asura uh
and we have the code from uh tiglak
pilizer which uh was 1100 years before
Christ but the code probably extended
even before that and for the first time
we see uh what it says it says if a man
secretly says of His companion one may
have unnatural intercourse with him or
in a brawl in the presence of men says
to him one has had a natural intercourse
with thee I will prove it against thee
but is not able so to prove it nor has
proved it this man shall receive 50
lashes Dune King's work for one month be
mutilated and pay one Talent of lead and
in the next one more clearly it says if
a man has had unnatural intercourse with
his companion if it has been proved in a
certain of him that he has had an
natural intercourse with him he shall be
castrated okay so castration was not
only for eunuchs in meaning people who
were slaves but it could be for someone
who um engage in homosexual sex okay so
uh these are um in this is in the code
okay we have that code today it's been
translated more or less okay I mean I
don't think you could screw up the
translation that much so that it's
completely understandable no we
understand what these people were
telling us from 1100 years before Christ
okay here's the hittite code okay uh
from around the same era
um
it only has one uh little chunk the rest
of it has nothing regarding
homosexuality and that is if a man has
intercourse with his son
and then uh you get to Leviticus which
is maybe five a thousand years after the
code of the head ties may be 500 years
after depending on you know when this
all started uh Leviticus probably dates
orally before 500 BC okay so keep that
in mind as well and we all know these
These are known as the clobber uh
Clauses of the Bible okay and you can
look them up there they are and it says
Thou shalt not lie with mankind as with
womankind okay why because otherwise you
will be put to death okay so the penalty
was death uh none of these cultures none
of them not one
uh favorite homosexuality they all
punish them severely it was frowned upon
you know you'll find a lot of homosexual
books today and they'll say well we were
always loved but then the Catholics came
around and they uh started convincing
people to hate us that wasn't the case
at all okay these people are simply
talking nonsense
um homosexuality was frowned upon from
day one whenever they saw it they said
what the hell what is that that's what
unnatural sex that's how they put it
okay and they were kind when they said
that okay and here you have the parts of
the Genesis okay the first book of the
Bible
uh the first one has to do with Sodom
and Gomorrah why is it called sodomite
uh uh to some sodomize someone well
because of this because it was it's got
to do with the city where this code
comes from and it was a code that
everybody just was born with you know I
don't think you needed to put in writing
but it was in the Bible anyways and he
used the word no for the translation and
you might say well what do they mean by
no it says bring them out unto us
talking about lot and angels that came
to visit him and the men's some men of
the Town surrounded the house and they
wanted a lot to bring the two angels out
so that they would know them what do
they mean well you see it in the next
sentence that says I pray Brethren do
not do so wickedly behold now I have two
daughters which have not known man okay
and he said do with them whatever you
want so I guess we know what they're
referring to when they say no okay
Corinthians the New Testament and Romans
they talk about effeminate man and men
doing it with men okay and it's all uh
yeah frowned upon nobody uh nobody
favored it there was no law natural or
otherwise or written law uh people
simply saw that as an Abomination okay
so uh yeah we do have uh in the record
we do have
um an idea of that of what people
thought in those days about
homosexuality and here we have Greece
you have the code of Solon okay and also
about 500 BC 600 BC and uh he wrote a
couple things in there related to uh
homosexuality xenophon talks a little
more about it and if you look up his
book and yeah he essentially says that
someone frowned upon sexual version of
pedestry
um Plato and Aristotle also said it was
not favored by the Greeks but if you
have any doubts you got to go to against
to Marcus you got to look up that uh it
was a trial
and it had to do with escanese as Kines
was someone who
um had gone to uh
give me a second here let me show a
little up again uh escanese had gone uh
he was a Athenian he was sent as an
ambassador to Philip II of Macedon up
north Macedon had a big army Philip was
beating up all the little city-states up
north and he was going to come down to
Athens and so they sent escanese up
there to pacify Philip and say look uh
yeah it'll be nice to us and so when he
came back and says hey we have peace I
have reached an agreement we have a
treaty with Philip and the most Denise
who was a very important man uh oratory
in Athens uh he he said look what they
what Philip did was bribe
escanese he bribed them so escanese is a
traitor to Athens okay and so
um they brought a trial against escanese
and the prosecutor was Demarcus
okay so to Marcus brings a case against
escanese and escanese does not defend
himself
saying that he's not a traitor that he
was bribed or anything like that he says
that to Marcos has no standing to bring
a case against him because to Marcus is
a homosexual that he's uh lent his butt
to the sailors in the pireos okay the
port the Athenian port and because of
that he had no standing to sue because
um he was not a citizen of Athens and
what you'll see in against Demarcus is
the whole Athenian gold against
homosexuality
okay so people today say oh all the
Greeks did all the Romans they did
absolutely not as people ignorant people
who say that okay or people who have uh
some political uh agenda
Athenians or Greeks in general Romans
they were all against homosexuality
there were laws against that and there
need be no laws because people had this
natural revulsion towards homosexuality
okay uh here you have the Romans
and they had the Lux scantinia and I
think it was uh who was it um
I don't think I can remember who it was
but it said uh the half half man the
half-man
um uh fears Deluxe scantena
and uh why because Alexia Antonia
punished homosexuality okay and uh so
the homosexuals who were still around a
few that were around they had developed
codes just like we have coach today in
the uh homosexual uh world where you
know they detect each other because they
know some of these codes okay but uh
essentially in Rome you know the Romans
in general regarded as a Greek Vice and
they would call it that
okay so uh no in in ancient Greece
um Rome Egypt uh Babylonia Syria all
cultures uh were against homosexuality
and I haven't mentioned the Aztecs have
mentioned the American Indians they had
the uh two spirits well there's a a
whole bunch of information out there the
Vikings also uh you'll find all kinds of
information out there and it was all in
every culture it was all 150 percent
against homosexuality so those people
who say that now I was accepted and that
it was forever that it's been there
since day one uh no
um we have to explain why it wasn't in
the code of uh Hammurabi and uh the
others like the Yokota Burr and so on no
they didn't have it in those codes and
so it could be interesting to speculate
that maybe homosexuality started
appearing or started appearing as a
problem
maybe anywhere from 11 to 1500 years
before Christ that's probably where we
can locate it according to the record
whether you believe the record or not
that's a separate issue okay but that's
that's my take on that okay you can do
your own research this is not for you to
believe it's for you to understand what
I'm saying some of the evidence that's
out there you can look it up and reach
your own conclusions
okay another fellow raises another issue
similar is the rise in autism
and general mutation Madness is due
referring to transsexuals right is due
to women delaying childbirth and their
resulting faulty eggs okay this doesn't
affect third world countries hardly at
all of course
is that true okay well some of it may be
true maybe the fact that women are
delaying having children at older age
men as well by the way you know so you
have women having babies at the age of
40 men having babies at the age of 50
maybe with a woman who's 40. yeah I
think uh that could be a serious problem
okay it used to be that girls would have
children at the age of 15. and today we
think that's rape
so uh culture has changed a little bit
okay
um so that's one side of it the other
side is you know uh whether um
uh whether it has anything to do with uh
what this fellow said you know and here
here we have uh some evidence okay uh
that I can provide to him that it's uh
not solely because uh people are old but
there are some genetic disorders okay
um in other words we have uh our gene
pool has been washed up okay we don't
have much genetic uh diversity among
humans and you can see this in the Amish
which is a small piece of the human
population very small piece
um here you see it health is
characterized by higher incidences of
particular genetic disorders especially
among the old order Amish these uh
disorders include dwarfism Angel man
syndrome and various metabolic disorders
such as la la okay as well as unusual
distribution of blood types almost all
Amish descent from about 518 Century
found I think it the number was more
closely related more closely to uh
either maybe two thousand fifteen
hundred maybe even three thousand okay
but okay uh the point is that it's a few
hundred okay generally resources that
come out do you inbreeding exist in more
isolated districts okay an example of
the founder effect and yeah there you
see some example Polydactyly is
associated with mutations okay it's a
genetic problem and I always have a
disproportionate uh number of cases
there they also have dwarfism there you
see an example and Angelman syndrome you
know genetic disorder that mainly
affects the nervous system symptoms
include a small head and a specific
facial appearance severe intellectual
disability yeah and it affects not only
uh Amish but relativists okay so uh so
be aware if you become a relativist it
might affect you as well
okay so what can I show you uh about
that I'm saying that
um this has to do with genes primarily
autism and homosexuality both have to do
with genetic uh these are genetic
disorders okay people are born that way
they can't do much about either okay and
uh why do I think that well
um there are several reasons I'm just
going to give you a couple of uh pieces
of evidence okay here's uh one which is
uh Calhoun's experiment which I've
talked about in the past and here you're
going to hear it more or less from the
horse's mouth uh lady who talks about uh
the experiments listen to this
the third period consisting of 300 days
found the population of mice leveling
off
the newer generations of young were
inhibited
since most space was already socially
defined
this time some unusual behavior became
noticeable
violence became prevalent
other young mice growing into adulthood
exhibited an even different type of
behavior Dr Calhoun called these
individuals the beautiful ones
their time was devoted solely to
grooming eating and sleeping
they never involved themselves with
others engaged in sex nor would they
fight
all appeared as a beautiful exhibit of
the species with Keen alert eyes and a
healthy well-kept body
these mice however could not cope with
unusual stimuli
though they looked inquisitive they were
in fact very stupid
Dr Calhoun called the last period the
die phase leading the population into
Extinction
although the mouse Utopia could house
three thousand the population began to
decline at 2200.
okay so um the issue here is that they
started with four couples and they let
the mice reproduce and so we have many
factors there that have to be considered
one of them is the fact that they were
crowded after a while right uh 300 days
or whatever uh there are lots of mice in
there and that's one issue and so people
say well you know you have Society here
we're all in the city there's a city we
have cities of millions of people does
that affect us does that affect our
mental state and then you have the issue
that other mice descended from four
couples okay so we were talking with my
son nans and we said look maybe the way
they should design the experiment next
time is
um create a uh holes so that
um as the population expands you open up
more space for them okay so the mice can
as the population gets to a certain
density you open up the gates so to
speak and they can move to a bigger
environment okay and so on you keep
expanding the the place but the founders
effect cannot be undone Elder mice
descended from the same four couples and
the question then is
um
if you're going to get the same result
if you're going to get the same results
you're going to get autism and you're
going to get homosexuality which is also
one of the issues that uh uh Calhoun
observed
um then it means means that uh it's the
founders effect that's what really was
the main uh factor that ended up with
that result okay so this is uh one of
the things you got to look at and then
of course uh for both homosexuality and
autism you got to look at you know what
I said the other day and here it is you
know you have lions and you have sheep
people say what's what we eat it's all
the poison that all these companies put
in the food and maybe it's climate
change who knows what they uh suggest
and they think it's uh you know maybe a
conspiracy by rich people to Corral the
poor people who knows but that's not the
case with lions and sheep and they have
homosexuality among them as well so uh
you know whenever you talk about uh
politics and you talk about poisons that
they're putting in our bodies through
through food or through uh whatever out
there the animals don't have in the wild
right do not have the same influences
and they're having the same results as
humans
so you got to look at the animals why
that's the case you can't just blind You
Know cover your eyes and say well that
never happened no you got to answer that
that's a phenomena okay and so if you
deny it but you're denying a fat now you
don't deny something that destroys your
theory which you got to go and find out
why it's the case Okay so that's all I
can tell you
okay uh another issue here uh we have
um atheism okay and this fellow says
this is incorrect definition you know
the the ones that I put up there uh an
atheist simply doesn't believe in the
god claims of others
they do not assert that a God can't or
does not exist
agnosticism is about knowledge not
belief you are putting you are posting
misinformation okay first of all uh let
me just say that knowledge and belief
are synonyms and so that's the first
answer to this vowel so the fact that
the this uh fellow says uh knowledge
that it's agnosticism is about knowledge
not belief uh oh he said is uh synonym
uh knowledge is Justified true belief
and no one has ever defined it any
differently as much as they twisted and
turned around they could never Define
the word knowledge knowledge is belief
because knowledge means that you know
but the other guy doesn't know the same
knowledge that you know okay and so it
comes down to belief and no you can't
turn into a stat you know in any way to
accommodate the word knowledge other
than as a belief there is no difference
between knowledge and belief knowledge
is just a stronger belief that's so you
define it maybe but it's belief can
ultimately believe okay but let's
address the other issue uh whether an
atheist doesn't believe in the god
claims of others
using the word belief keep that in mind
it's not about belief but uh atheists
don't believe
and we'll find this from all atheists
and by the way I used to be an atheist
for most of my life so I'm a little bit
ashamed to say that but uh today I'm not
an atheist what am I am a scientist
scientist is different than an atheist
atheist is the religion of math and
magicians
of people who don't know the scientific
method that's why atheism is still
around otherwise we wouldn't have
atheism okay so atheism this is from
around the Wikipedia is the in in the
broadest sense is an absence of belief
that's the way they see it so yes it has
to do with belief because either you
believe it's an absence of believe it's
denial of belief what are you saying
you're saying the opposite of belief you
disbelieve I mean you can put any word
you want in there this believe not
believe refuse to believe it's got to do
with believe it's just the opposite of
belief okay and
um
let's brought the atheism as a rejection
of the belief right that uh any deities
uh deities exist okay so yeah
um and it's contrasted with theism so
yeah that's what atheism is that's why
it's a theist that's the opposite of
theism atheism is the belief in Gods
well then atheism is the disbelieved the
non-belief the refusal to believe
the knowledge that you don't believe
that there are gods or that there is a
God okay so here's uh what American
atheist says uh says what is atheism
atheism is not an affirmative belief
that there is no God nor does it answer
any other question about the what a
person believes which this fellow said
yeah we we don't believe what the other
person believes but see here they say
the opposite they say uh that doesn't
answer any question about what a person
believes it's is simply a rejection of
the assertion that there are gods and
notice that they avoided the word belief
when they're saying the same thing in
different words the rejection of the
assertion means belief and that's an
opinion anyways which again is a belief
so they haven't said anything
and here you see the next uh another
line there so to be clear atheism is not
a disbelief in God or a denial of God it
is a lack of belief in Gods
so uh they keep saying the same thing in
different words that's all they do they
just keep changing chasing their tails
around okay uh says they do not believe
in Gods those people are atheists and
and there they prove again because they
say
um that if if you do not believe in a
god you're an atheist and here they just
finish saying that uh that's not what
atheism is so they keep contradicting
themselves because they continue coming
back to the word belief they cannot uh
avoid it and they're the one of the
statements they have in there says
atheism is about what you believe
so uh yeah they keep chasing their tails
around they want to avoid the word
believe but at the same time they use
the word belief every time they want to
Define atheism so they haven't said
anything I like to say that atheists is
an individual who believes in bores
planetary atom because that's their
symbol the icon they use there is uh the
planetary atom which is ridiculous
that's what atheism apparently believe
in today and I call it the religion of
the mathematicians why because uh
mathematicians have this mathematical
method which has to do only with
evidence prove persuade convince convert
recruit all those words there all the
way to award prizes and Authority that's
what uh the mathematical method is all
about it's about persuading convincing
people it's about recruiting and that's
what's not that's not what science is
about science is not about proof we
don't prove the existence of God or the
non-existence of God and we do not force
our opinions on other people okay that's
not what science is about so this is
where we part company with the atheists
and Atheism is simply an attempt to
prove that there are no Gods okay or God
there is no God
and that's not what we do in science in
science we say something very different
we say let us assume
that there is a God we make an
assumption God can only be an assumption
God cannot be a theory we do not prove
the existence of God we make the
assumption that God exists and then
proceed from there to explain our Theory
maybe that God created the universe or
whatever whatever you're going to
explain next but God is an assumption
and can never be a theory okay it never
can never be an explanation okay and
people don't understand that that's
where the epicity atheists because they
don't want their religion being
destroyed
okay so uh here's uh American atheist uh
again uh they say the following they use
this little trick uh word Wizardry UK
says
uh what is religion well this is me it's
uh belief opinion and as this does this
not does this make uh not believing a
religion if you don't believe are you
also a religious person that's the
question and so atheist says not
believing
is not a religion okay so if you don't
believe that doesn't make you a
religious person because religious
people are people who believe not people
who don't believe and they say it's like
uh stamp collecting you say if you stamp
collecting is a hobby right is not
collecting stamps also a hobby
that's in the context in which the
atheists put this non-belief and it's
not a fair uh analogy okay because in
the case of
um a belief it's an on and off you know
black or white type of issue you either
believe or you don't believe and if
you're going to call it disbelief you're
going to say withhold believe I don't
know if I believe you know all you're
doing is just rolling around in circles
okay believe has nothing to do first
with existence so you should not never
use the word belief in terms of
existence okay because as soon as you
put believe or disbelieve or not believe
or any way you want to phrase it all
you're saying is all you do is give me
your opinion okay in science We Don't
Give opinions the science we explain
objectively so someone understands for
that we make an assumption we say let us
assume God exists and you can explain
all you want okay okay so uh here's uh
my definition of atheism
from American atheist this is how they
go around in circles okay Atheism in a
nutshell we do not affirm that God does
not exist they do a not not there double
negative we reject the assertion that
God exists whatever that means okay so
all they said is the same thing in
different words they're trying to avoid
the word belief and that's all they're
doing here and they say atheism is not
about belief okay what is it about you
know atheism is the disbelief in the
belief of others
so they twist and turn it and uh bend it
any way they want they always end up in
the same way why is this the case
because this comes from mathematicians
they have the wrong scientific method
they've had it all the way since the
days of Newton and uh
Galileo 17th century so-called
Scientific Revolution uh no it was a
religious Revolution to this day we're
doing religion in official science in
mainstream so-called science majoring
physics it's not science what they're
doing what they're doing is uh uh you
know trying to explain with equations on
one hand they're doing experiments and
measuring and then inferring and they
take those inferences and they turn them
into facts and they shove them down your
throat saying we proved it that's that's
mathematics in a nutshell that's why we
do not agree with
mathematicians okay they have the wrong
scientific method and that's why they
are atheists and atheists again they
have never figured out
um the scientific method that's the
whole issue okay so uh here we have uh
this is what uh atheists like for you to
believe that atheists are opposite to uh
religion to religious people and we'd
rather put it like this atheists are
religious people they are religious
people because they talk about belief
belief is opinion and we don't care
about religion in science we do not say
that we believe or don't believe in the
existence of God or that we don't know
whether God exists or not we Define the
word exist
and then if God meets the definition of
the word exist he exists by definition
pursuant to the definition and if he
doesn't meet the definition of exist
then God doesn't exist by definition
pursuant to the definition of exist so
we Define uh exists as an object that
has location if God wants to exist first
he's got a for anyone who makes that
assumption right giving a presentation
he's got to first uh present God as an
object he can't say God is a concept
that's why we need to determine whether
God's an object or a concept and a
concept is a relation between two
objects therefore it can't be a
standalone thing that you can illustrate
we do not illustrate relations
God is an object or God is a relation
okay and if you prayed a relation well
you're praying to an inexistent God
because that God does not meet the
definition of exist exists an object has
to have location if it has location if
God has location for example we'll
assume he's a human uh human form as the
Bible says fine then there's got to be a
distance between my chest and his chest
very simple okay then God has location
God exists by definition and that's my
assumption I'm saying let us assume that
God exists now you can follow my
presentation because I've made a case
for uh the assumption that in other
words you have to accept my assumption
at face value to understand my theory
that's the only purpose of the
Assumption that's the way it works in
science not hey I believe in God no I
don't believe in God and I don't know if
God exists no that's not science that's
religion okay all of it
okay uh here we have
um a rundown of that of the mathematical
method atheism is the religion of
mathematicians okay it's the irrational
scientific method why because they harp
on evidence on proof on knowledge
verification they say we must verify
your results none of that has anything
to do with science okay in science we
explain objectively so that you
understand
the mechanism that we're proposing and
we're talking about physics here okay
physics we're interested in mechanisms
in How the Universe works we want to
know what gravity is we want to
understand what uh magnetism is and for
that we make assumptions and from those
assumptions we build our Theory and if
you want to introduce God no problem we
have no problem with you introducing God
you have to introduce but if you're
going to talk about God like you know
God made the universe or made the
perfect world where the B Buzz buzzes
around the flower no problem but you can
make your case but you have to begin by
making God exist and for God to exist
he's got to meet the condition he's got
to be a physical object he can't be a
concept like love okay or or
intelligence and that's so he's got to
be something you can be a wall he could
be a chair I don't care what you think
of God but it better be something that
has shape okay uh that which has Shake
that's the definition of an object and
that's not enough he's got a God wants
to exist he's got to have location as
well okay then you can say okay he has a
way of influencing something in the
universe otherwise if God is a concept
or God doesn't have location then God is
irrelevant period
okay and so there you have uh exist um
they have uh never defined a word exist
they've never defined a word object so
we don't have the two words that we need
to do to determine whether
um God can be used as an assumption as a
thing as an existing object okay
and uh yeah there you have the two
definitions object that which has shape
and in order for God to exist he's got
to have location and until the
mathematicians learned those definitions
and challenged them because they're
willing and they're welcome to challenge
them uh but they have to produce a
definition for the word object and for
the word exists that we will gladly
we'll we'll be glad to tear the pieces
okay if it doesn't meet those
definitions
okay another fellow fellow comes around
the same uh notion and this is why this
topic was brought up here in the
extinction segment uh has have we had
the same religion always since man
invented religion and this is his uh
take on this he says God didn't become
an abstraction in the New Testament he
became flesh and blood
and he's talking about Jesus you know uh
God not here on Earth that's that was
his notion and so that's not what we
were referring to here last time when we
talked about this we were talking about
something else we're talking about
religion not about whether
um Jesus uh is God himself or the Son of
God which was a big fight in the fourth
Century whether you know uh whether it
was three gods or one you know this this
sort of thing no we don't care about any
of that that's not the issue the issue
here is has the religion changed over
time okay
uh what was God originally and what is
God today that's the question has God
remained always the same fellow or the
same thing or the same concept or
whatever and the answer is no obviously
God has changed just like you know we
you used to have many gods polytheism
and then they eventually moved to one
God okay and so we originally had a God
for every purpose you know God of the
wind God of uh the rain Etc and God of
the Sun you know Etc
um and from there we moved to a single
God you know monopolized all the power
in one one fellow up there okay and and
we always thought of God as someone who
resembles a human not not as or I can't
say always but uh when when we started
talking about a single God that God was
always a human it wasn't a cow it wasn't
a you know a lamb or anything like that
it was a human okay he looked like us
that's where the Bible says you know he
was we he he may Us in His image because
God looks like us okay God does not look
like a cow or a bull or a tiger or
whatever okay so here you have uh the uh
Old Testament okay and you can see that
uh the way they look at it there in in
the Old Testament right is that God
created man in his own image and you
hear some or read some uh evidence that
they're talking about a human being you
know someone who talks someone who walks
someone who listens right what are we
talking about we're talking about human
okay and the fact that he created man in
his own image says it all you know we
are made in the image of God according
to the people who wrote Genesis okay the
New Testament a little different okay uh
God is no longer this human being who
creates the universe uh he turns into a
ghost and here you said the Lord is the
spirit where the spirit of the Lord is
no one has seen God at any time yeah you
can't see a ghost I guess a spirit God
is spirit says John and he whom no man
has seen or can see okay so
uh it's no longer this God that has arms
and legs you know that God disappeared
with a new testament we're talking about
a different kind of God now the fact
that this fellow said well God came to
Earth and turned into Jesus and and he
came Flesh and Blood that's that's
missing the point completely God can
turn in the Old Testament and God turned
into a flaming Bush also does that mean
God is a flaming Bush no no it means
that you know what is God when he
doesn't turn into something else what is
he up there in heaven is does he look
like a human well the Old Testament says
yeah the Old Testament says he looks
just like us he's got a head two eyes a
nose a mouth arms legs you know body he
looks like us he looks like a man in
fact unless that changes in the future
okay
um
and uh he doesn't look like he doesn't
he's not a concept he he's not love he's
not Spirit like the New Testament says
and like they say today there you have
uh today's version okay and here's a
couple of people uh out there a couple
of
um pieces of evidence that say that what
you know what these people are trying to
say is that God is intelligence okay and
you see this across the board and why
why did they have to turn God into a
concept called intelligence well because
you know the mathematicians proved to
the world that the earth and the
universe had a beginning in a
singularity uh and so these people say
well we don't disagree with that yeah it
started in a singularity but how did the
singularity come about and they said
well it wasn't really a man you know a
guy with uh arms and legs no it was
Intelligence that created you know some
kind of
um uh in intelligent design meaning
came from the mind and they they won't
say what's underneath the Mind where the
Mind where this mind is located they
just say it came from my mind an
intelligent mind because only a mind
could have created such a perfect
universe or could have created anything
and so they they they suggest they
insinuate that there is a human being at
the end of that yellow brick road but
they're not putting him in the picture
they say look there's an intelligent
design intelligence created The
Singularity and from there we have the
universe they had to do that because the
mathematician pretty much proved to the
world you know that the Universe had a
beginning and so these people don't
disagree with that they just say yeah we
don't disagree it's just that uh we have
to say how to Singularity came to be
and general relativity stops at the
singularity well these people go further
back and they say well
uh we think uh we know what happened in
frame number one and that's intelligence
created this intelligent design there
was a designer and the design is the
mind just thought just intelligence that
created the singularity that's where
we're at today and don't put it past
them because uh what's happening now is
maybe not only are we turning that old
God that was you know like a man you
know because he we talk about he and him
right we don't talk about her or she but
you know with this transition that's
going on out there don't put it past
them that they're gonna be
um having a female god in the near
future and here you see uh one of the
people who protest against the clobber
passages in the Bible which are the
homosexuals and they created the Queen
James Bible okay so uh get ready you
know uh the Bible's about to change
again God's religion the whole thing
works is gonna change one more time
uh we haven't stopped yet we're still
thinking about what God is
okay
okay so uh
let's move on to the subject matter
today which is
um Wormhole okay
and
the question is what is a what is a
heart
what is a wormhole okay we were trying
to get to that uh to this thingy that
the mathematicians talk about they
research it they do a lot of equations
out there
um
are we wasting our time and money time
is money right so are we wasting our tax
money on Research in worm homes what is
this about is this just for Hollywood
movies so we say hey we're going to
travel through a wormhole to another
universe and blah blah blah you know a
great fantasy but they say it's not
fantasy it's uh science
is a science does this belong in science
does do we have to have any
mathematicians on planet Earth working
on this stuff at all or even thinking
about or even pondering it as even a
remote possibility
that's the issue I mean is this Wormhole
something we even have to talk about in
science
is it do we even have to criticize it
well let's find out where we stand we've
been doing
um lately the universal movie uh to
different concepts and we're gonna have
to apply it to the wormhole so what is
the universal movie let's start there a
little quick introduction most of you
are familiar with it but for new
arrivals they probably don't know what
I'm talking about so let's go quickly
through that here we have the universal
movie and what we're saying is all
static Concepts while in a single frame
of the universal movie whereas all
Dynamic Concepts the ones at the bottom
uh they require at least two frames in
the Universal movie now this is a little
different than what uh Quantum I'm sorry
general relativity has okay both special
and general relativity for that matter
and in fact it's throughout the
mathematical World okay and they have to
have this notion that time is not the
same at the other side of the universe
as it is over here so they don't like uh
they're they're not against they're not
in favor of this Universal movie idea
they don't know about it but they're if
if they heard about it they would not be
in favor of the universal movie why
because they say it depends on how you
measure
time
and of course someone over there is
going to measure time different than
someone over here because they have
different Vantage points okay a
different reference points they're
traveling at different speeds so their
measurements are going to be different
we don't care about any of that that's
all nonsense
the universe every atom in the universe
only has location in one frame of the
universal movie from there it moves to
the next frame of the universal movie
and people say well but there's a
um itinerary in between absolutely not
we're going to chop that itinerary as
much as you want until we get almost no
motion at all we're talking about frames
in the movie every atom in the universe
just moves to a next location
and motion is built through location
motion is two or more locations of an
object and what is the location with
respect to all other matter in the
universe so every frame in the Universal
movie only has location a static concept
there is no Motion in that frame so all
this nonsense about special relativity
how you measure and how I measure time
and and for you it's faster for me it's
slower my clock ran faster years ran so
we don't care about any of that that's
all papika nonsense it's uh hogwash okay
so uh yeah the universal movie destroys
this notion that there's different times
in the universe in fact we don't care
about time we talk about location a
static concept and we go from location
to location because that's what motion
is if you don't like the definition of
motion has two or more locations you
have to provide a definition of the word
motion you have to tell us what motion
is and not like Mr Newton said uh I
don't Define motion because everybody
knows what it is yeah
and to this day nobody has defined the
word motion they Define it as change and
change is motion so change is just a
synonym that's not a definition we can't
use the word change to define the word
motion
okay we say two locations that that
everybody understands because we have
two static Concepts uh transform into a
dynamic concept called motion okay so
here where we put Dimensions the
something that we're going to talk about
today lately we've been talking about
these and we said look dimensions and
coordinates are static concept whereas
what the mathematicians use which is
number lines are Dynamic Concepts why
because a number is the verb to count
that's what the word number means it's
to count we also have vectors at the
bottom line because a vector is a
concept
that has something moving from a to the
B it's a displacement and that's what we
call Vector okay and there are three
ways in which you can move from a given
point uh they're all perpendicular to
each other orthogonal and there's thus
breadth and elevation those are the
three vectors okay depth breath and
elevation and those are all those all of
those involve motion okay so that's why
Vector is a dynamic concept whereas
coordinate which is about location and
um
Dimension which is uh how something is
pointing or facing
both of those are static Concepts
okay we have to get that straight
because uh we ended up with
um uh these black holes that we
discussed the other day the zero
dimensionality the world of the Zero D
is there such a world is is that a
dimension called the zero Dimension okay
and where did we put that well we we
don't know where to put it because uh
really a singularity and a black hole
are both Concepts but they treat them as
physical objects they're not they're
Concepts and uh so we have a problem
because if they're objects if we're
going to treat them as objects they're
static objects black hole does not need
to move it's just something out there in
the sky okay that suppose he has
location with respect to us the problem
comes in that both the black hole and
the singularity are Zero D okay as we
explained the other day and if there's
zero D they're not objects and so the
problem here is that we have a
contradiction between whether a black
hole in a singularity are objects or
concepts okay so this is where the
problem is but if they are objects we
have to put them as a static object
neither The Singularity nor the black
hole move in fact we cannot imagine a
zero D moving anywhere because the Zero
D is not an object so we need to
locations of an object to create motion
and we don't have an object to begin
with so I mean I mean how you move how
are you going to move a zero D nothing
from A to B you have nothing what moved
that's the issue
okay so what's the issue the
mathematicians because they have never
defined what a dimension is in a
scientific way they never Define what a
coordinate or a vector is in a
scientific way they confuse them with
number lines uh because of that
um they ended up with irrationality so
they ended up with
multi-dimensional universes and here you
have rundown okay this is the
multi-dimensional world of mathematics
mathematical physics we have the 26th
dimensional world of string theory known
as bosonic String Theory we have 11
dimensionals of M Theory brains 10
dimensional super strength Theory okay
those are all from string theory and
they have to have all these dimensions
in order to explain gravity or or
somehow merge quantum mechanics with
general relativity okay the world of
particles are very small where the world
of the macro world of cosmic you know
the universe
then we have the Colusa Klein Theory
from 1921 uh five-dimensional universe
okay they needed five Dimensions to
explain how this universe works
otherwise it wouldn't work then we have
the four dimensional one uh that people
uh like Einstein came up with he was he
wasn't the first one uh even before that
you have minkowski and uh uh pankare and
so on you know all these people already
had come up with these ideas uh Einstein
simply took the credit for it uh we have
the 3D euclidean world that comes from
uh euclide
euclides Greek uh philosopher whatever
you is uh just a guy who tried to do
some geometry okay the 2D world of
euclidean geometry the planes
um then we have the 1D line they say
they call it the 1d9 but there's no such
object no such geometry is a 1D line the
1D is not an object it's not a figure as
we explained the other day Okay so
there's no such monster turns out the
we're going to argue today is one D
we're going to get into that and then we
have the Zero Point Zero Dimensional
Point what is that well it's nothing
but they say that's what a black hole is
that's what the singularity at the Big
Bang was it was nothing okay Zero D is
nothing it's a definition of nothing
okay so let's find out how uh what we're
gonna do with this we've got these
Dimensions here we have one uh fellow
who uh you can see why it confuses
people like this this uh gentleman here
who also got confused because uh the
mathematician never defined dimensions
and coordinates and vectors and so he
uses these words you can see hear how
he's going to use them and it shows that
he's got a lot of influence from the
math and magicians and he was simply
brainwashed by them here here's you can
see it here okay speaks for himself says
graphene is composed of a single layer
of carbon atoms arranged in a
two-dimensional honeycomb lattice it is
a fundamental building block for a range
of well-known carbon materials such as
three-dimensional graphite
one-dimensional carbon nanotubes and
Zero Dimensional uh following okay so
where does he get all this stuff well
again he he's using these words uh from
mathematics he's not talking about
dementia he's talking about number lines
okay not about dementia not talking
about length width and height which
belonged to physics he's talking about
number lines and those don't have
Direction Number Nine does not have
Direction they put an arrow because they
say numbers increase in that direction
but there is no Direction you can put
numbers in any way you want you can put
them without a direction okay what the
two is not in front of the one and the
three is not in front of the two you can
put them in any way you can put the
three behind the one and then the two in
front you can do whatever you want with
numbers they have no location
okay and so it's when you put them in a
line that it confuses people they think
they're talking about a line
which is what one dimensional uh yeah uh
please draw it and then he says the
two-dimensional motions
two-dimensional motions no no motion are
not dimensional okay you can talk about
vectors maybe number lines but you
cannot talk about two-dimensional
motions no such monster monster
okay so um where did uh wormholes uh
come out of uh originally I mean how do
we end up with one-dimensional wormholes
who who came up with this nonsense okay
and here we have famous father his name
is Hermann whale yeah or vile in German
he's the inventor of the topological
idea of wormholes in space-time he was a
student he was a person who studied
Einstein quite in detail he wrote a
couple books uh regarding general
relativity so he's one of the head
honchos in those days in the 20s okay of
general relativity he pushed for general
relativity uh Wales spoke of
one-dimensional tubes
well when I think about tube I think of
a cylinder you know like a hose maybe or
something like that you know and this is
not what he's telling me one dimensional
two like a contradiction in terms what
kind of tube is a one-dimensional tube
please draw it
okay and this is where where we have
problems with what these people say
because they say one-dimensional tomb
nobody challenges that and they get away
with murder that's what's happening okay
inside these tubes no space exists
first of all space cannot exist because
space is an not an object and only
objects can exist because the word
exists is an object that has location so
he's using the wrong notion of exist
he's got to define the word exist before
he can use it and he's just saying that
it exists or doesn't exist now space
cannot exist space is nothing nothing
does not exist it's objects that can
exist if they have location not space
which is not a thing never has no
location okay so again we see the faulty
language that all these mathematicians
use and that's why people get confused
out there and their boundaries are
analogous to infinite distance
inaccessible so what they do they put it
beyond your graphs they say it's
infinite it's at Infinity go over there
and so you say well I'm not going to go
over there I'll just accept it and
that's what they do they accept it on
the basis of authority because the guy
used the word infinity or infinite okay
that's how they get around these things
okay wormholes thread
through space as air channels through
swiss cheese okay so this cheese has all
these holes so what do they explain
they're explaining tubes going through
these this cheese right space having all
these holes through it and they're
one-dimensional tubes
we cannot even picture what these people
are saying they cannot picture it they
cannot draw it okay but they get away
with murder electricity is not
electricity electricity is electric
lines of force trapped in the top
topology of the space okay so we have
electricity in there somehow it's uh
these holes in space okay well did not
use the term wormholes it was John
Wheeler who later uh coined the term
wormhole in 1957 okay so yeah
um
uh Hermann Wale did not come up with
that but he had the idea okay the idea
of the Wormhole already and
um
here's uh how he defined it essentially
Einstein's spatially closed universes
often referred to as Einstein's cylinder
world with two of the spatial Dimensions
suppressed
okay so they take length width and
height that's what they're talking about
okay they're going to remove two
Dimensions they're going to leave blank
or width or height one of the three
right but look at what they say
um
um they suppress two Dimensions the
model Universe can be pictured as a
cylinder
cylinder with one dimension okay where
the radius a represents the space
radius what's what radius can you have
with one dimension if you took two
Dimensions out
and the axis the time coordinate in
other words what is that single axis
it's time
and that's what uh whale was thinking
about when he was thinking of
um
his famous Wormhole he didn't call it a
wormhole but that's what he was
referring to he was referring to one
dimensional what time what is time is it
a dimension no it's not a coordinate
it's not a vector it's a number line
that's what time is it's not a dimension
as mathematicians want you to use the
word to Define it or to characterize it
okay so we're talking about time that's
what the Wormhole is it's time and here
you have
um another vision of that okay
uh you have this Wormhole that uh they
say you can cut across space by thinking
of a space as something that's curved
around okay and they're going to have
time go through this from one place to
another shortcutting uh the trip around
that uh that whole region there so
they're just gonna have uh you moving
through this so-called Wormhole and what
is that Wormhole you're traveling
through time you're traveling through
one dimensional time meaning a number
line they're talking about you know a
number line you're traveling through a
number line a one-dimensional one number
line they're not talking about anything
that's thick they're saying it's a tube
but the tube is one-dimensional and
they're referring to time
so yeah it's very uh very confusing okay
because they cannot illustrate what
they're saying that's the issue they
cannot even imagine what they're saying
that
okay uh so what is the definition of a
wormhole uh is it a thing is it an
object well here you have wormholes uh
this is one fellow who uh I think this
is out of the Wikipedia it says space
can be visualized as a two-dimensional
surface
uh-huh not true because space is nothing
so it's not a surface and suit not
two-dimensional and you cannot visualize
it space is absolutely nothing we take
all the atoms from the universe away
somehow uh we have absolutely nothing in
front of us
in this case a wormhole would appear as
a hole in that surface so here they
create a two-dimensional flat surface
think of it on a piece of paper even
though it's 3D but try to think of it as
a flat sheet of paper okay completely
flat and you're going to put a hole in
there in there so now you're looking at
from the top and you're saying well
that's a surface now okay so you're
looking at the hole from above and you
see a surface okay
um lead into a 3D tube
I thought it was a 1D tube now they they
turned it into a 3d2 the inside surface
of a cylinder yeah a cylinder is a 3D
but that's not what a
uh Wormhole is Wormhole is One D as Mr
uh whale told us okay and that's also
what Einstein referred to when he
created this monster then re-emerge at
another location on a 2d surface with a
hole similar to the entrance in other
words they're referring to black holes
they're saying that the ends of a
wormhole are zero d uh singularities and
those are the centers of black holes
okay so we have a wormhole that's
connecting two black holes one is in I
guess one Universe the other one in
another universe or different points of
space or however you want to think of
them okay and as you can see it's um
it's so realistic what they're showing
you there but people love to draw
wormholes I mean you've got millions of
people out there drawing Wormhole
because they absolutely love the concept
okay and they try to illustrate in their
illustrating papycon that's what they're
illustrating illustrating something
which has no possibility of even you
being real okay an actual Wormhole would
be analogous to this but with the
spatial Dimensions raised by one uh-huh
what do you mean spatial Dimensions
raised by one for example instead of
circular holes on a 2d plane the entry
and exit points could be visualized as a
spherical holes in 3D space leading into
a four-dimensional two similar to a
sphere in there or sphere in there okay
it was a sphere in there well that's a
geometric object they say Okay defined
as the Cartesian product of a three ball
or a solid two sphere whatever all that
nonsense means a radius R1 and a line
segment the line segment what is that
that's going to be time
so it's not a line segment they're
talking about time which is a number
line it's not even a line
uh like the duo uh cylinder it is also
analogous to a cylinder in three space
which is the Cartesian product but this
with a line segment okay let's find out
what a Duo cylinder is it's a geometric
object again it is it uh embedded in a
four-dimensional euclidean space defined
as a Cartesian product of two discs well
all the images that you see on the right
which uh apparently are the Wormhole the
serener and the duo cylinder as you can
see they're all
um 3D projections under uh uh onto 2D
surface so all the images are 2D but
they're trying to project a 3D image
onto a 2d
none of those are 4D and you cannot
illustrate the 4D that these people are
trying to explain in a roundabout way in
fact even the famous uh
warp space time that uh mathematicians
does since the days of 1915 or even
earlier uh even that is 3D
all of these images are 3D projections
on onto 2D none of them are 4D and you
cannot even imagine the 4D let alone
picture it illustrate it you can have
depict it you cannot draw an image of a
4D no matter how you try in fact if it's
got time
embodied in it you're talking about
motion so you're not talking about a
static image like you know a table or a
rock you're talking about something in
motion
when you stop it meaning no time what
you have a 3D 3D you have the table so
they're saying a table that moves
is a four dimensional tape that's what
they're saying and a rock that moves is
a four dimensional table because now you
have to include time in what you're
staring at so you're talking about a
movie not about a static image that you
can just illustrate that's why they
cannot illustrate the forward D because
it's got time in it
okay
um so here's another fellow but he says
that uh it's not an object like these
people are trying to tell you all these
so-called objects this is all uh he says
that it's a mathematical concept and
nothing but and he's uh prominent in
quora so you can find him very easily
his name is Victor Toth I talked about
him in the past and he says the
following about wormholes he says
wormholes in general relativity are
mathematically valid Solutions of
Einstein's field equations the equation
that describes gravity and curved space
time which
um uh connect uh distant regions of
space okay so he's saying that look it's
just the solution to an equation so this
nonsense about you know uh there being a
tube out there in space connecting
different points of space that's
nonsense
so he doesn't say it that obvious that
he doesn't believe in this nonsense but
he just uh
suggests insinuates that maybe they
don't exist of course they don't exist
it's because it's poppycat it's nonsense
okay so um here you have it this is what
the Tesseract is okay which is uh
another notion that they have for the 4D
and all it is is just an expanding cue
that's all that the Tesseract is there
is no
uh such thing as a test rank it's not a
four-dimensional object because the only
way you can present the Tesseract is in
motion and you're talking about time
that's what those Corner uh lines are
they those are indicating time
so none of the objects that these people
present are um
r4d and likewise you cannot present the
Zero D which is the so-called
Singularity that's uh gave rise to the
Big Bang or is in the center of every
black hole there's no such monster as
Zero D and likewise there's nothing like
the 1D which is what uh the Wormhole is
alleged to be because the Wormhole is
just timing that's all it is and that
time is a number line and so they talk
about Dimension they talk about twos
some call it the 1d2 the others call it
the 3d2 because you can picture that a
cylinder and people say okay I
understood that yeah you understood it
but you're not understanding you're not
understanding what the Einstein Rosen
bridge is and so they went a step
further and uh it was Einstein and a
couple of his buddies who came up in
1935 with two concepts that created a
lot of this stuff okay they expanded on
Mr Wales notion and they mathematized it
okay here it is
um Einstein podolsky and Rosen they came
up with epr that's what epr stands for
Einstein Podolski and Rosen and uh they
um they were criticizing quantum
mechanics in 1935 they didn't like
quantum mechanics so they created this
uh thing which today is known as
entanglement okay and a couple months
later uh Einstein and Rosen they came up
with ER the particle problem in general
theory of relativity where they um
also you know um went in there and said
well you know how do we handle uh things
such as wormholes and that's where the
Wormhole came into being formally with
ER okay and so what happened since then
well we had this uh these uh two
individuals uh one malda Santa person
from uh
co-national or mine and another fella uh
suskin
those who know him Leo suskin from
California and he proposed the following
they said ER is equal to epr they're
both the same and it's uh what they call
a conjecture okay in physics and this is
essentially what what they're referring
to which is essentially the definition
of a wormhole today it states that two
entangled particles a so-called Einstein
Podolski Rosen or epr pair are connected
by what a wormhole or an Einstein Rosen
Bridge which is the second paper that
the Einstein wrote that a couple months
later right ER equal epr is thought by
some to be a basis for unifying general
relativity and quantum mechanics into a
theory of everything that's why it's so
important to these people because if
they can say look a wormhole that goes
through space and connects to uh black
holes is pretty much like uh you know
the whatever that connects two particles
during entanglement you know this
particle affects that one over there
instantaneously we'll uh wormhole in
space connects two wormholes
instantaneously and so it's a conjecture
why because they haven't proven the
existence of wormholes they claim to
have proven the existence of black holes
right and so uh yeah they're working on
this because of that and Leo suskin and
Juan mother Center in 213 uh proposed
that a wormhole is equivalent to a pair
of maximally entangled black holes okay
so they're using these words to try to
unite uh general relativity with quantum
mechanics that's what's so important to
them that's why they're working on it
that's why they're spending your tax
dollars on this nonsense
PR refers to quantum entanglement you
know the epr paradox
okay so
um
this is what it looks like okay
uh you can see there the um
uh on on the one hand you have epr on
the right and you have ER the uh
Einstein Rosen Bridge which is the
wormhome one is Cosmic and the other one
is here in the lab uh you uh you can say
that the one on the left has to do with
general relativity the one on the right
has to do with quantum mechanics and if
they can get those United well you can
see where they're going with all this
they're trying to make sure that you
understand that what's between two
particles is a wormhole
and what's between two black holes is a
wormhole what is a wormhole it's a
one-dimensional time which is a number
line that's what they're talking about
so when you're traveling through a
wormhole yeah you're not training
through a 3D tube cylinder you're
traveling through time
that's what they're saying so uh that's
what all this nonsense is all about
okay so um where do we put the wormhole
in our Universal movie is it a static
concept is it a is it an object
is it a dynamic concept what is a
wormhole okay and here we have it we put
it as a dynamic concept that's what
they're referring to why because it has
to do with time okay so that's what the
issue is Wormhole is time in fact it's
not having to do it is time whenever
they talk about Wormhole they're talking
about time time is what is it one
dimensional no it's one number line
Wormhole is time time is a number line
that's all they're talking about so when
they say you're traveling through a
wormhole you're just traveling through
time okay
um
can we talk about holes in general like
you know and I'm not talking about those
kinds of holes talking about or nose
holes right no we're talking about black
holes and wormholes okay
can we talk about Holes without there
being something into which the hole goes
or through which the hole goes through
okay and that's the the question here
you have a groundhog hole okay we all
can relate to that that's more or less
what a groundhold
uh groundhog uh
groundhog hole looks like underneath the
ground okay it looks something like that
what if we were removed to remove the
trees and we removed the groundhog we
removed the ground we remove everything
except the hole what would we have well
we would have something that looks like
this
that's what a groundhog hole looks like
without everything else that's what a
hole looks like a hole is a concept it's
not a standalone object so you will not
have a something there you know for you
to see your touch or whatever okay so
there's no such thing as a whole whole
is a concept okay so uh what happens to
a wormhole well they show you something
that looks more or less like this and
they say that's a wormhole everybody
looks and says yeah I recognize that's a
wormhole but what if what is the
Wormhole through well it they say it's
through space
okay the the whole perforate Space
because you're gonna go from one region
of space to another you're going to
enter one black hole Zero Dimensional
black hole gonna go through this tube 3D
tube you're gonna end which is a hole
really through space and you're going to
end up or you know come out of a black
hole on the other side of the universe
or maybe in another Universe for all we
know so if space is nothing what is the
black hole through
well here I'll show you I'll illustrate
that for you here it is that's what it's
true that's what a wormhole looks like
without space okay because if space is
nothing the hole is absolutely nothing
as well okay
so uh yeah uh what can we say uh this is
what you're traveling through when
you're saying that you're traveling
through space okay
this little thing here
okay so what what can we conclude
where I'm home is not a thing and so
it's very hard to put it into a static
concept because it's time
and a synonym of time so you're
traveling through time and so time is a
dynamic concept we we would put it
um under the universal movie would put
it together with the Dynamic Concepts
and then the other thing is that without
space you have no Wormhole the only way
you can have a wormhole if space is
something if it's a thing you can you
can run a hole through swiss cheese as
they were saying or you can make a
gopher hole if you have the ground
without the ground without the Swiss
cheese you have no hole okay so let's
get that straight first and likewise if
a wormhole is through space
and uh if you remove space from the
Wormhole you have no hole and you don't
have to remove space because Space by
definition is nothing that which has no
shape there is nothing there so it's as
if you remove the ground from the ground
hog hole and it's if you remove the
cheese from the holes in the cheese
swiss cheese right uh then you have no
holes and that's what happens to the
Wormhole Wormhole is absolutely nothing
just like a black hole
with that I'll see you next Sunday we'll
see you then bye bye